when we started the landmark alpha we  didn't know what to expect we did  something we'd never done before we  asked our players to help design our  game to say we were pleasantly surprised  would be an understatement in fact every  time we set a bar you raised it when we  gave you blocks you made castles when we  gave you claims you built cities  when we gave you rules you broke them  you created things that didn't exist  shrinking voxels down to something you  called micro voxels then you created  anti voxels which seemed to change the  very laws of physics in landmark we've  been amazed and inspired by your  creations we'll be giving you more tools  and features to work with most of which  we've told you about but some of it will  surprise you  we're proud to announce our landmarks of  landmark competition join players from  around the world and build spectacular  creations the best of them will be  featured in landmark permanently